[Music]
I'm Kirk Bray and I'm Chris pray and we
are really cook
[Music]
he always knew we were gonna do
something together we just didn't know
what and we always knew the name was
gonna be Billy Kirk because that's what
our father would call Kirk we would go
to this pawn shop in Santa Monica
California and Curt really like this
watched round from the 70s the guy
didn't want to sell it because it had a
watch on it but you didn't bag in bag
then finally he broke he broke down
show me the watch strap for $25 right
yeah I was wearing watch strap at a
coffee house I worked at people were
commenting on it they really liked it
and it's sort of the idea just sort of
kind of strength in that he basically
walked in and said I figured it out
let's make these yeah and then from
there you know wallets and bags and
everything came yeah I mean I think one
way that we've that were sort of
different is that you know I mean we've
been using the Amish for around 10 years
now to to make most of us and all the
other goods we do some stuff in-house
but they're making it in a way where it
looks like the eighteen hundred's you
know in their space you were trying to
design create something that got better
with age to the to the point where you
would pass this thing down there's a
architect in Milan and there's a
skateboard defendant that used the same
bag so I don't know what
really television pot our demographic
what it says about them is they care
about how things were made you know
they're spending a good amount of money
and they want something that's gonna
last I think it also explains just how
the customers changed and how the
customer has gotten a lot smarter and as
cares about those things now because you
know it's made in the US because it's
made with integrity it's pretty special
I mean to to be a part of that and it's
what sort of makes us excited about it
[Music]